hey this is pressure Walker I want to
discuss two math problems that are
generating headlines worldwide because
media outlets are saying they are
stumping the internet right now the
first problem was given to fifth graders
in China if a ship had 26 sheep and 10
goats aboard how old is the ship's
captain the second problem was given to
second graders in the u.s. there are 49
dogs signed up to compete in the dog
show there are 36 more small dogs than
large dogs signed up to compete how many
small dogs are signed up to compete I'm
gonna go over each of the headlines of
each of these problems and then go over
a little bit of discussion about each
problem so let's start out with the
first problem here's a sampling of the
headlines generated worldwide about it
from the South China Morning Post 26
sheet plus 10 goats equals a lot of flak
over Chinese primary school maths exam
question from RT 26 sheep 10 goats and
ship's captain unsolvable math problem
puzzles Chinese students from the BBC
unsolvable exam question leaves Chinese
students flummoxed from the Washington
Post this Chinese math problem has no
answer actually it has a lot of them and
from Newsweek can you solve it bizarre
math exam question leaves Sudan
scratching their heads in China so there
actually was an official response they
said the question was not a mistake it
was meant to be open-ended to encourage
critical thinking so how might you
estimate how old the ship's captain is
the most sensible answer I saw that was
quoted in the BBC comes from someone
who's comforting on Weibo the total
weight of 26 sheep and 10 goat is seven
thousand seven hundred kilograms based
on the average weight of each and
now I did a little bit of fact-checking
and if you type in 26 sheep weight plus
10 goats weight into Wolfram Alpha the
computational search engine you actually
get seven thousand seven hundred pounds
which is approximately three thousand
four hundred seventy kilograms so I'm
not sure exactly where they got that
number of seven thousand seven hundred
but let's just go with it for the rest
of the answer in China if you're driving
a ship that has more than five thousand
kilograms of cargo you need to possess a
boat license for five years the minimum
age for getting of boats license is 23
so he's at least 28 or the ship captain
is at least 28 so there could actually
be some interesting critical reasoning
from this problem but to give it to
fifth graders as a math question it just
seems a little bizarre and so that's
what generated all these headlines
around the world and it's very bizarre
that the official answer was that this
was not a mistake and it was meant to
encourage this kind of critical thinking
so now let's move on to the second
question so there are 14 dogs signed up
to compete in the dog show there are 36
more small dogs and large dogs signed up
to compete how many small dogs are
signed up to compete so this seems like
a standard algebra problem but it also
generated a ton of headlines PopSugar
reported the Internet is losing its
expletive deleted over the second-grade
math problem The Daily Mail mother is
left stumped by her seven-year-old
daughter's maths homework question but
could you work it out from the New
Zealand Herald math question for
seven-year-olds breaks the internet from
forbes this is actually from contributor
kevin Knutson who has a podcast my
favorite theorem which I encourage you
to check out here are an article what
about medium sized dogs so how can we
solve this problem
let s denote the number of small dogs
and let L denote the number of large
dogs as there are 36 more small dogs and
large dogs we have the equation
equals L plus 36 there 49 dogs signed up
in total so s plus L equals 49 we then
take the second equation and substitute
s is equal to L plus 36 so we get the
quantity L plus 36 plus L equals 49 we
can group the L terms so we get 2 out
plus 36 is equal to 49 we then subtract
36 from each side so 2 L equals 13 and
we divide by 2 to get L equals 6 point 5
now s is equal to L plus 36 which means
s is equal to 42 and a half but what is
half of a small dog or half of a large
dog the answer of 42 and a half small
dogs just doesn't make sense
clearly this should have made it a cat
question and at least people could have
made schrodinger cat jokes which could
have compensated for the very bizarre
answer now PopSugar did reach out to the
teacher who responded that the district
worded the problem wrong and it was a
mistake so the lesson here is that math
textbooks and teachers are allowed to
make a single mistake you know in this
case we would have had a proper integer
answer for an even number of total dogs
signed up for the show so we don't need
to freak out after every single math
mistake
but surely people will freak out so I'll
be seeing you the next time the
worldwide media goes berserk over a math
problem thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog my your decisions if you like this
video you can check on my books which
are listed in the video description and
you can support me on patreon if you
have a topic for discussion or a puzzle
you can email me at presh at mind your
decisions calm also let me know how you
wanted to be credited by first name and
country or however you can also catch me
on social media either at my near
decisions or at pressure Locker